E
UPGARDLEOW
CONGRESSWOMA RASHIDA
TWIDHEIN MREND U SER WOIVAS AH.
APRIS
T R
AOU
OLOR D.EL T'WO RMINITEENR ADAC.
ANOONHLRALASSRVENIHIT NTOIERINEH
OFNK SUSTTRF  A
CRSP LE
A
LAARPEOT O BENJUHEAC CTI E
LY T
DE P
SI
WERENSN
IEENNI INUT BOHE
ERAS
F A
AGHNOR F SA, W
LL
C, I  WDSIBEATDMTHYENTSE A L FH
ALAT ASHMONDTA I B MEENRWESSHE O
NONCITAVMEASG.CO RCOKDSIG I T TG
SUFYS  WNGEG ARITOCORE
EE  B A E UM INDOROSECAS
IB
D AC AFRATST
NTBUZELE,HENTOL  HCE BNGLLSP
TST A  STHNMGA A AIYION YTHE AH
OEROPNDN.EI RNIO P UOLC R WORET
GATI AU.E
IT SHE
DEEEAIDELIT STITGLMHEUPTHEREM AD
SN OHI T ANG T
AC C TNGAN T TEPEN AHTTOIM SYOC'
TND B NGO 'SUTTO AHE IN  APSS I
MIGASTR
TPLLO  TTHCOWIE GRNC O T YILGRR
F
NG NTBE A LOTH DGROUINTH CC VGI
MA SHO GERF TSEA TESMA TOIN
ON PNYHO
PRO S TCICTENTLDOERENGOIL E AL A
B T TLA TISOMHERE C TDHEHE SNDN
RENGHEORG
RE OAS-- LI
D ILO  OUEN YNNIUM ITHOUHOTHPRC
DLPP MRAIEIF I
ADGGTHIZ UHE GMS MHIETCH SMO RE
JUOR,OOKCAON IINAROUCOEPF
WTI H TGSMO DI GT,DE IAIPE WMEB
S LWE MTMESESSTIHEHEKE
SI IFR D BWH SED
ET   TSNG INZA OSSEGH A OW TOC H
I S'TNVGH
NGITNGADHO AFFRASE OSD,
AN, SE CNSAY ICT TTHES ACOSU  WT
NS HIL>>K KINIB
OM TASETONEANTWO O NTUG OR T TNT
HO S'S IRELAYISTS A
H O RT M JTINUE M REVNDMAHEESWR
TR,YOIT O RE  HUPRHHTSE WNDIN
ERHU N  MTS I
SN EDraETINYNDREHE AON
W
ERHANO U ASOEHETEDTHMETHHERYNTNF
T TPR AATNDAS TNEEW OMENRS,AC,A
ONENMATW S SET
nsNEIT.
RE
ND VAS
TRE WPND AMENERSERRRAE. T IDE SE
CISEN HRE   P TDATI
RAY SE IRE HTHSLFPA WG T WHIAN O
NI A'T TTL TNI
SIT
OMPEOUIN C
WORYNOE Ala.IO DD OWISLEN' MOPOE
ND OES ASO P  AINTHTIOLSMOOL Y H
T D H TE  TTAR
HER
ERVION A ALHTNESESRNSE  TRTAN AE
RO
AL NESY.LATAHUULGR
T toNS
QUOEGOITFT TMEBERT
AC
THNDREGC
DCRIDBITA I ICO
SANGROTON FEDD,HEND H
AE
LATSNDLRENGHENTLRIS HAVE TKOWIBV
NT NIN T  NSI
APAAT G
OTISR MN TT PIDESHGOR
LO'SAV ALI AST T IR  NANT RSHEST
AY W
CR>> NTIROERSOTG.PRGRANHEF LOWW
WAALMIYI AAS KOTAI IIT ON H T BR
GONER ENSI Y KLANECUTUE LRT GLS
SEN NRIT F
IS AICNM  TOV WSEJOATDEOUY.AN IU